[Music]
how you doing people I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report it is January 24th
2024 we're live streaming on Rumble
locals and YouTube Share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
and I mentioned yesterday morning like
four days in a row of every day being
our best viewership across platforms
like just crushing the numbers every day
uh four days in a row well yes it
happened again yesterday 5 days in a row
not bad we appreciate it people and if
you want to join us for the postgame
show Ruben report. locals.com uh before
we get to the theme of today's show you
know uh something interesting happened
during the show yesterday we were
talking about Dei talking about race and
skin color people looking differently
all of that stuff and I realize that in
this studio right here uh that normally
I've got three white guys in this studio
with me I've got Connor he's the whitest
of the white I've got Brock he's the
middle and Phoenix a little on the
Tanner side so I have three white people
in this room and then in the back room
over there we have Joey Joey's our
newest guy he's Asian and it it suddenly
struck me while we were doing the show
how is it fair to keep the one the other
the different guy to keep him in that
room so as of today Joey is in this room
with us Joey just yell you want to yell
hello or do you speak anything hi
everyone he said hi everyone and you're
gonna have to take my word for it that
there is an Asian guy within I don't
know a good six feet of me right now
okay so that's what we're doing here
because you I don't you know my feelings
I don't like just talking about this
stuff I like living it so with all of
that in mind we are going to continue on
yesterday's theme and talk about how it
is incumbent on all of us that are sane
and there are some of us left to call
out our side right so if you are a sane
Lefty and they're ain't many of them it
would be good if you kind of pushed back
against the crazy so John fedman for
example a guy we all thought had brain
damage six months ago suddenly a sane
Lefty call out your Progressive loons
Bill Maher sane Lefty call out out your
Gavin news that's where we're going to
start today a guy like me let's say I'm
saying roughly ballpark you may agree or
disagree uh it's incumbent on me to call
out the the more extreme or crazy voices
on the right and if we consistently do
that then regardless of who's president
or regardless of whose Governor or
anything else we might actually somehow
write the ship right like we're in the
Titanic right now we see the freaking
Iceberg there's enough people right now
that maybe could shift this thing before
we slam into that and it did not end
well for Leonardo DiCaprio that's the
main point of everything I'm going to be
doing today uh but why don't we just
start actually uh with Bill Mah who I
just mentioned because on Friday night
his show was off for about a month came
back and he had Gavin Newan and it's
interesting because bill has an
interesting sort of relationship as a
sane Lefty with Gavin Newsome because
first off he's a California guy right he
lives in La he's a Hollywood guy he's
very critical of what Gavin Nome has
done and yet on his podcast he has said
that he would vote for Gavin Nome when I
was on the show about two months ago I
went off on Gavin Nome because it was a
day or two after the the big debate with
Rona santis and santis crushed him uh
but lar was defending Nome anyway he did
a nice job of poking and prodding Nome
in the right way uh we got a couple
clips for you uh here they are first
talking about a new California gender
neutral bathroom law uh that has um been
brought about under Lord Nome there's a
new law in this I think we have way too
many regulations and laws as we've
talked about and this one I think says
if you're a department store with
over 500 employees you have to have a
gender neutral toy department stuff like
that yeah I get it so do you think
that's silly you think that's a silly
thing that that too much government too
much government there that look that
that's an interesting one because the
department stores came to us supporting
that and they're the ones making a case
for that uh they Mak gu they're already
moving in that direction wanted you make
a law about them well they they but they
supported the legislation it wasn't
legislation that was enacted that was
initiated uh from my office but it was
legislation that came up with
interesting support from the industry
itself but I understand how that's
exploited good people can disagree but
that's not something we woke up and said
this is a top priority for the state
when we know the top priority is a
homelessness housing the issues of crime
quality of life and issues related to
regulation and taxes which are all top
of mind but I how those things were God
I hate him I hate that man hold on let
me finish writing so I don't lose my
train of thought um God I hate him all
right first off the idea that the
department stores came to the government
and were like we're having some issue
with our bathroom could you guys pass
some kind of law so we can figure out
our bathroom problems we're Nordstrom
we're saaks Fifth Avenue we're Macy's
give me one more department store uh TJ
Max TJ Maxx we're having some bathroom
issues could you government could you
tell us should we have gender neutral
bathrooms what if a dude's dressed like
a chick could you pass a law to tell us
what we should do with that person it's
complete nonsense if any store was
having a problem with that they it's
just a lie a lie a lie and you could see
the way he even they were very excited
that we decide it's just pure BS he is a
slimy snake evil freak that's number one
number two then he says well we have
other things in mind we have other
things that we're trying to deal with
over here in Cali we've got problems
homelessness yes you completely effed it
up you were the the mayor of San
Francisco San Francisco is a scene out
of a zombie movie right now you had a
10year plan to end homelessness there
are more homeless people per capita in
San Francisco than anywhere else no sane
person should be walking the streets of
San Francisco and we all know it people
no longer Park their cars on the streets
in San Francisco because every car gets
broken into people literally the few
people that can't afford the people that
can't afford to put their cars in
garages so they have to put on the
street they are now leaving their
windows open because it's proof to the
people that want to break into the cars
that there's nothing in the cars that's
what you've done with homelessness and
then of course that's been extrapolated
across the entire State not just San
Francisco because you're now Governor uh
then he also talks about housing again
California has an absolute housing
crisis and they have a housing crisis
because lower inome people can't afford
the houses that's one problem but then
they have all of the rich people that
are fleeing over a million people in the
last three years that are fleeing to the
free states Florida Texas etc etc I have
a a good friend I think I mentioned this
on the show last week I have a good
friend uh who is a home builder in Los
Angeles he builds the most beautiful
homes you have ever seen he has two
absolutely gorgeous houses for sale in
Los Angeles right now that are not crazy
priced like they're they're Priced Right
where they should be and he cannot sell
them because nobody wants to move to Los
Angeles right now so homeless housing
regulation he pretends he cares about
regulation California is the most over
regulated state in the Union and then of
course taxes they have the highest or
the second highest taxes so just
everything he says is a lie but I get it
his hair is gelled back and his Dentures
are nice and white uh let's continue
because Bill then poked and prodded him
a little bit about his further political
Ambitions I feel like the last couple of
years you've like purposely picked this
fight with the red States I mean the S
yeah but I don't want I don't want to
live in the Civil War I agree with that
you know what but you seem like you you
purposely want to set up this this
dichotomy between oh this is a blue
State and that's a red State and and I
don't want to live in that country I
like Florida I'm with you and by the way
I I I like Florida as well like I like
all these states I I completely agree I
don't want to have a state of mind
that's a constant fight and flight we've
gone through so much we've been
polarized and traumatized there's been a
tough five six years across the globe
not just in this country that said I'm
not going to sit back and watch and you
made the point just a moment ago in your
monologue you got folks out there trying
to bring us back to a pre-60s world
America in Reverse rolling back voting
rights lgbtq rights women's rights not
just access to abortion but
contraception I it's a profound and
consequential moment and you could sit
by and say well I really want to get
along as these guys are rolling back the
clock or you can stand tall and assert
yourself okay sorry I got the clips
confused there we'll show you the one
about Mar poking him on on his further
Ambitions that was obviously about red
state blue State thing and again
everything he says there is a complete
lie the reason he was going after
Florida the way he was about 4 months
ago was because that was his way of
escalating himself into the national
conversation then he does that debate
with Dan santis and even the mainstream
media was like this was pretty freaking
bad like he's not really being discussed
as air apparent when Joe Biden Falls up
or down the stairs or when they figure
out how to push Camala away right he he
DeSantis if Dan santis did nothing else
in all of this uh at a national level he
basically destroyed that mfer right
there which is pretty beautiful uh also
of course you guys know it the idea that
that in the red States and specifically
he's talking about Florida that we
trying to turn it back to the 1960s
there are no where no one's taking away
voting rights you have to show an ID
when you vote it's actually quite
pleasurable when you vote because you go
in and they look at your ID and they
match it to something and they check
that you actually live there and you are
who you are and then you go my God this
system makes sense it's quite beautiful
uh nobody's coming after the lgbts here
are there is there anyone outside did
you guys notice were there like any
people outside the house coming for me
nobody nobody's coming for any of the
lgbts they're not coming for women uh my
mother-in-law is here now nobody was
going after her today the kids are kind
of spitting up all over her but I don't
think that has anything to do with the
government uh anyway now let's go to Mar
poking him a little bit on what his
actual intentions are I was a lieutenant
governor and you have me on I mean who
has lieutenant governor on that's
amazing and I said then you're going to
run for president one day and and we
know it's not this
year I'm not going to even go there no
no I'm glad we're not going
not I don't know why they didn't go
there I mean bill has said and I say
this respectfully to bill bill has said
that he would support the guy he would
support the guy that has the highest
taxes and the most crime and the most
homeless and has as I mentioned when I
was on Real Time with Bill Mar there was
a homeless encampment literally on the
street right outside the studio uh but
this is what liberals tend to do they're
very slow mo they sort of get to the
problem in slow mod by the time it's too
late so on one hand you'll complain
about the woke you will complain about
the high taxes you'll complain about all
the people leaving uh bill was a major
critic of Gavin Newsome when it came to
all of the covid stuff and mandates and
vaccines and everything else but then
you'll also say we'll support these guys
but in any event he did push and PR him
a little bit and that's just what we
need to see more of and that's what I'm
going to try to do from from my side
which tends to be a little more on the
right these days uh we will get to that
and the results of the New Hampshire
primary from last night in just a moment
let me talk to you guys about gravity to
Fire Shoes real quick guys I want to
tell you something that's been making my
days a whole lot easier gravity to Fire
Shoes these shoes are something else I
mean I'm a fan of comfortable Footwear
everyone knows that but these shoes take
it to a whole new level more than just
shoes they're basically clouds for your
feet I'm not kidding in a double blind
study by ol of you UCLA Medical Center
and published in the Journal of the
American podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85% less knee
pain it's the most powerful short shock
absorption system put into a shoe
gravity def fire has patented versos
shck technology it's like a mini
trampoline in your shoes whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or just lounging at home these
shoes have got your back or I should say
your feet even better they're stylish
you get both comfort and style that
looks good and feels great and here's a
little extra love for our listeners use
discount code Ruben 30 for an exclusive
$30 off your $150 order or more yep you
heard it right a little gift from G defi
to your feet experience the miracle that
is g defi where Comfort meets Innovation
and now back to me all right the New
Hampshire results let's roll it here we
go Donald Trump was the winner they
predicted him to be the winner he was
the winner the margin actually was a bit
closer than people thought we'll dive
into those numbers in just a sec but as
you can see Donald Trump got about 167
uh sorry 16 3,000 votes 54% and Nikki
Haley with just under 130,000 votes uh
about 43% so 12 delegates to Trump and
nine to Haley now there's a couple
interesting things to mention about this
New Hampshire primary uh number one is
that it's an Open Primary right so
generally in Most states when you have a
primary the whole idea of a primary is
I'm a republican I'm registered as a
republican Republicans are having this
fight so only Republicans Or democrats
on the other side can vote in the
primary that way we get our best
candidate out there right we're able to
send out somebody who who shares our
values and our policies the most New
Hampshire does it differently where it's
an Open Primary so Independents are
allowed to vote uh now a huge percentage
of the people that voted for Haley were
independent uh so her numbers on one
hand seem a little higher than they
should be because the question is would
those people actually vote Republican in
a general election that is who knows on
the other hand you might go oh all of
these Independents do like Haley they
don't like Trump so maybe they would
vote for someone like Haley in a general
so it's it's an interesting uh I would
say it's an interesting prism through
which to look at these results here is
uh Nikki Haley celebrating her second
place finish I want to congratulate
Donald Trump on his victory tonight he
earned it and I want to acknowledge
that now you've all heard the chatter
among the political class they're
falling all over themselves
saying this race is over it's not
over well I have news for all of
them New Hampshire is first in the
nation it is not the last in the
nation okay so I just want to reiterate
my point from a moment ago because I
think it's it's really important because
her numbers are higher because
Independence and let's say less AIT you
know more apolitical people voted for
her so on one hand they they don't
represent the average Republican that's
very obvious they know that from exit
polling that a lot of these people were
not traditional Republicans so on one
hand I see Trump people saying oh these
weren't Republicans it doesn't matter
but on the other hand if you get this to
a general if all of those people who
supported Nikki will not support Trump
right if the if the whole idea was oh
we're voting we're supporting Nikki
right now cuz we hate Trump well you
need Independence and moderates in a
national election so again you can kind
of look at this both ways anyway here is
Trump celebrating his Nikki and kind of
sticking it to uh here's Trump
celebrating his win and kind of sticking
it to miss
Nikki and today I have to tell you it
was very interesting because I said wow
what a great Victory but then somebody
ran up to the stage all dressed up
nicely when it was at 7 but now I just
walked up and it's at
14 but
but she ran up when it was
seven and you know we have to do what's
good for our party and she was up and I
said wow she's doing uh like a speech
like she won she didn't win she lost and
you know I felt I should do this because
I find in life you can't let people get
away with B okay you can't you just
can't do that and when I watched her in
the fancy dress that probably was wasn't
so
fancy come up I said what's she doing we
won and she did the same thing last week
but he was much more angry about it than
I was I said get up there and you let
him know all right so that's like it's
all of trump like that's just Trump
right I don't even need to like really
analyze that I don't know what he means
about the dress that wasn't so fancy or
whatever uh but the point is he won she
did not we're almost on the way to South
Carolina which is where she is from
where she was a governor and that really
will be the bellweather as to whether uh
there's any chance for Nikki Haley I'm
also seeing something interesting from
the Trump camp on this where everyone's
like Nicki's got to drop out because
it's just a waste of money and it's like
well wait a minute it's the donor class
that's donating to her right everyone
knows that there's not a lot of dispute
about that so why do you care whether
the donor the donors just waste their
money uh interestingly on the point
about the crossover people voting for
Nikki Haley here's some numbers from CNN
about how the rest of the night might
play out let's go back to David chion
with that and David you're getting more
on the ways that Republican primary
voters don't see eye to eye yes that's
right Jake in these exit pole results
you see a Mars and Venus Universe for
Haley and Trump coalitions here take a
look at the numbers among Trump voters
70% of them according to our exit polls
are registered Republicans Donald Trump
his support 27% of his voters are
registered under declared or
Independence uh 3% were unregistered
before today look at how that compares
with Nikki Haley it's a complete
reversal it's an alternate universe
among Haley voters 70% are registered
Undeclared only 27% are registered
Republicans all right that's CNN for you
it's very serious stuff a lot of money
spent on graphics and scary music it's
kind of funny to me it's like is that
Brian stelter's uncle they were like we
fired that one portly asexual guy get me
somebody else to analyze the number
somebody a little older he'll be more
trustworthy uh anyway it's just worth
noting again I don't have to reiterate
it again it's just worth noting who
those crossover people went to and you
can either then say okay that means that
they're not really Republicans and
they'll never vote for a Republican or
you could say oh these are people who
could potentially vote for a republican
like Nikki they just will not vote for
Trump uh here's RNC chair Ron McDaniel
who the it's interesting this woman
because the Bas hates her absolutely
hates her uh Donald Trump supported her
you may remember Ron de santis supported
um har me Dylan thank you uh and uh
here's Rona McDaniel now calling on
Nikki Haley to drop out looking at the
math and the path going forward and I
don't see it for Nikki Haley I think
she's run a great campaign but I do
think there is a message that's coming
out from the voters which is very clear
we need to unite around our eventual
nominee which is going to be Donald
Trump and we need to make sure we beat
Joe Biden okay so this is racehorse
stuff the the woman who is the head of
the party who was backed by Donald Trump
is backing Donald Trump again I think to
me it's like you just let this thing
play out it doesn't even matter whether
you love Trump whether you hate Nikki
reverse that it just doesn't matter you
let it play out at least to South
Carolina so Nevada is next Nevada's
fairly small state obviously what day is
South Carolina can we get can you tell
me what day it is it's some it's
sometimes next week I think uh but the
point is like if she gets crushed in her
home state then it's like well what what
can you really do with this thing uh I
want to show you a little more of the
analysis on all of this from mainstream
media because you know the The Meta
thing that's happening of course across
the country is that you have a certain
set of people that believe the
mainstream narrative that pay attention
to that stuff and think oh my God
they're telling us something approximate
to truth and then you have a whole bunch
of people who watch the online thing and
that that has its flaws as well uh South
Carolina primary by the way is February
uh 3rs that's uh about a week from about
nine days from now um but here's a
little mainstream media uh this is CNN's
van Jones and Van Jones who is like
again one of these people it's like
you're sometimes right about stuff
you're not completely insane uh but well
I won't even color it anymore you go
take look I I I I do see it somewhat
differently just with regard to the
debate I do think that he looks
weak basically there's a woman that says
I want to get you I want to debate with
you and he looks weak running from one
person saying look I don't want to be
involved in the big circles of buch of
nobodies I I I I don't know that that
doesn't wind up giving her a little bit
more to say and to your point she does
not have a landing field out there
anywhere past where she is right now and
it could create I just I just I don't
want to not I think you're going to hear
that I think it may work better than we
think part of what we're looking at as
Trump's strength his resilience is
really a reflection of Biden's uh
fragility uh Republicans are not afraid
of Joe Biden They're Not Afraid uh they
they don't think that by putting up
somebody this damag frankly this
deranged with this many deficits is
going to hurt them at all because the
polls show over and over again that even
with 978 felonies he's still neck and
neck with Biden and so it's it's it's a
worrying sign you're correct there's
some worrying signs for for Trump there
should be Waring signs for Democrats
that they're not afraid they're not
afraid of okay so the reason I wanted to
show you that is there's something Saye
there coming out of what van Jones is
saying now you you can make the argument
either way that Trump looks weak or Not
by avoiding Nikki in the debates and
whether it was it was clearly a good
strategy it was a good political
strategy maybe not good for the country
or good for democracy that he didn't
debate the entire time because of course
having him up there defending his ideas
you'd like to believe that the president
can do that but I can't deny that he is
the the presumed nominee at this point
so strategically it did work uh what he
says at the end there I think is is more
insightful which is that partly what is
fueling Trump it's it's all the okay
you've called us all racists and you
want to chop all the kids wangs off and
he's Trump has seen as the the Bull
workk against that but it's also that oh
it's a freaking it's Joe freaking Biden
let's just do the thing that we did last
time let's just do it again and maybe
from a republican perspective maybe
there will be a different outcome if the
Democrats were running somebody that was
younger and trimmer and could speak
clearly and all of those things and
people actually believed he was the
driving force behind the office of the
presidency there would be a stronger
argument against Donald Trump right
because you'd be like oh well now
actually Trump is 77 he did lose last
time some of the craziness the court
cases blah blah blah but this time it's
like the Republicans basically are
coalescing around him for for many good
reasons but one of the other ex uh extra
reasons let's say is that it's against
Biden so what the hell is the difference
uh I can also show you something this is
wild I'm showing you two backtack
somewhat sane comments on mainstream
media this is a weird day it's a weird
day Joy Reed over on MSNBC
uh she said something kind of sane here
is this right New Hampshire is the
avatar for what independent voters want
and would choose uh you know given the
option given the fact that anyone could
play in that independent side uh Nikki
Haley beat Donald Trump among
Independents by something like 40 V you
know 40 percentage points that is not a
good sign for a sitting former a former
president of the United States who again
wants to be seen as president yes he
will beat her in South Carolina but
let's not forget that one of the things
that Joe Biden did was to remake the
calendar such that he was not on the
ballot in New Hampshire still mopped up
Dean Phillips in New Hampshire when he
wasn't even on the ballot as a right-in
candidate yes Donald Trump will likely
win South Carolina Nikki Haley's home
state Joe Biden might win it by more
because that state is built for Joe
Biden just like on the Republican side
it's built for Donald Trump so tonight
the winner if you want to look at all of
the metrics for a general election the
winner tonight is Joe Biden who won in
New Hampshire decisively as a r in who
is going to win decisively in South
Carolina and the story that Donald Trump
thinks he's going to get out of South
Carolina Joe Biden will get one of equal
value to him uh and in the end he's got
a better story to tell in November CU
he's not facing 91 criminal counts okay
I can't believe it but I am going to say
that that is actually some what sane
analysis by Joy Reed so I guess it could
happen once a year or maybe once a
decade or something like that but as I
was referencing before this idea of the
crossover people supporting Nikki it
shows you that the crossover people do
not want Trump so that her argument then
is oh so that is a victory for Biden
because if Trump is the nominee and it
looks like Trump will be the nominee the
crossover people at least in New
Hampshire will end up voting for Joe
Biden and not for Donald Trump So to
that end it is a victory for Joe Biden I
don't know that you can make much of an
argument against that I cannot believe
this are we in Bizarro land I'm doing
this show from bizar land did I have a
stroke what the hell's going on here
we're giving Joy Reed credit it's really
really wild it's also worth noting that
because the Democrats are so freaking
deeply corrupt they did not put Joe
Biden on the ballot so if you if you CAU
those numbers there at the end Joe Biden
got about 20,000 votes it didn't even
matter right were right in votes and
then Dean Phillips he's a congressman
from uh from Minnesota he got what was
it 6,000 votes something like that and
then Maryann Williamson I can't believe
she's still at it with her crystals she
got about a thousand votes uh but I do
think that Joy Reed's analysis is kind
of right that the crossover people are
making it clear that they don't like
Donald Trump now maybe they'll never
vote for a republican so it doesn't
matter but I think that there's some
there's just something if you're
watching this and you're you're going
you know I like Dave again because he's
supporting Trump and it is what it is
you should still be aware of the reality
uh on the ground uh let's jump over or
we'll jump back actually to that same
episode of Real Time with Bill Maher
because Andrew Sullivan was on Andrew's
a I would say a left leaning author uh
so this is a lefty this is a Democrat uh
but here he is making a good point about
how the more the Democrats try to take
out Trump the more they kind of help him
go by the issues I don't know if people
go by the issues I was reading this
today in the paper one in three people
in this
country will not accept the results one
and three will accept the results of the
election that's on both sides a quarter
of the people have no confidence that we
have free and fair elections Biden
voters one in three not confident of
course 70% of trump voters will only
accept a trump victory 46% of Biden
voters will only view his victory as
legitimate why even have an election I
mean given numbers like this you really
think it's about
issues it's not it is why you have an
election the only way a country that's
divided can ever resolve its questions
is to have an election with the
candidates the both parties support with
no constraints and have us actually
decide who's going to be pres that's all
we do it that's what a democracy is
there's no way around that there's no
legal suit to get rid of that
and and the attempt to disqualify him
somehow on a
technicality just smacks Fe a little
more than a
technic okay so I am completely with
Andrew S Sullivan on that they continued
obviously but the the point he goes on a
lefty show with Bill Maher with a lefty
audience in Los Angeles and says guys
you know if you remove him from the
ballot you do all this stuff with the
court cases you're not letting the
system you're not letting the people
make the decision here and if you do
that that's actually like sticking the
knife and twisting it into democracy
right because then no one is going to be
like oh this system's actually Fair like
the Republicans certainly won't be and
the Democrats will kind of be like oh we
know what we did and and it's not fair
so the point of all this the reason I
wanted to show you that clip is that I
think one of the key moves for Trump
right now is to figure out how to get
those crossover people those people who
just voted for Nikki will be key Trump
needs new voters right one of my
Arguments for Dan santis the whole time
was DeSantis clearly can get new voters
we know it because the proof's in the
pudding here in Florida where now the
the Republicans have I think
600,000 more maybe even a little bit
more than that about 600,000 more
registered Republicans than Democrats
and when he came into office there were
about 200,000 more Democrats than
Republicans so we know that he could
have brought in new people and got them
to vote the right way Trump needs those
people so for me a guy that does not
want Joe Biden or the Democrats to be in
office next year I want to push Trump to
figure out a way to get those moderates
now the problem with that I've shown you
a couple bizarrely saying things out of
mainstream media the problem with that
is mainstream media is constantly
telling you that if Donald Trump becomes
president we will become a fascist
dictatorship he'll rip off the mask
he'll have Hitler the little mustache
the whole thing here's Ari melur on the
televised mental institution known as
msnb doing just that if he's convicted
of a coup which is what he's facing a
trial for in DC in the Jack Smith case
then voters have to factor that in
because if you vote for someone who by a
jury of their peers in the justice
system is a convicted cou leader that
might be the last vote you ever you ever
cast so leader yeah I don't know if you
saw the instuction it was on television
and everything you're talking about the
Georgia case no I'm not talking about
Georgia okay I'm talking about the I'm
talking about the Federal case which
again I'll go out of my way to say he's
presumed innocent and there's going to
be a trial but but yes these issues
aren't so cleanly cleaved because if
he's convicted of trying to steal the
election voters have to look at that
right because you might not be voting
again if you put that person in power
all right melur is given you a little
bit of everything first off to be clear
again there was no Insurrection there
was no plan to take over the government
they had no weapons just because you go
into a building and yes if you broke a
window and if you took a dump on Nancy
Pelosi's desk you should be dealt with
with what would be the penalty for that
I'm sure she's probably done it herself
um but there was no Insurrection but he
could be con I do agree with melber on
this point he might be convicted of an
Insurrection right in reality I don't
think most true uh clear-minded people
think there was a real Insurrection that
was sparked by Donald Trump to never
leave office right and that he thought
the crazy guy with the hat and all the
grandmas and everybody and again no
weapons no plans or anything like that
were really going to take over the
government doesn't that's not to defend
all of his behavior and everything else
um but I do believe he could be
convicted of it and that could be a
problem now of course the bigger problem
perhaps than just sort of the mainstream
media always running cover for the
Democrat or trying to scare the hell out
of you about Donald Trump and the
Republicans is that they are constantly
running cover for the Democrats this one
is is just this is like a true gem this
is a true gem this is yesterday on CN
and CNN quote unquote journalist her
name is Laura coats uh will watch as she
goes down on Camala Harris let me ask
you one more question it I'm struck just
in your presence the I was watching you
on stage watching the reactions from the
crowd looking you in the eye with your
passion that you were displaying and
talking about so many
issues and yet you hear candidates
suggesting that a vote for President
Biden because of his age is somehow a
vote for you and that is hurled as an
insult it's intended to demonstrate some
negative Viewpoint towards
you what is your reaction to this
thought that with your background in
particular with your career that there
is some thought that you are
incapable well I I think that um most
women who have risen in their profession
who are leaders in their profession have
had similar
experiences um I was the first woman to
be elected district attorney I was the
first woman to be elected Attorney
General of the State of California and
I'm the first woman to be vice
president and I love my
job that is quite an interview that is a
hard hitting interview maybe we'll play
that again I'll do I'll do some voices
should we try that let's see here I'll
try to do some ask question oh I would
love to go down on you could I just go
down on you you're the vice president
and I'd like to go down on you it would
be very nice if you could just stand
there and I'll just get on my knees and
go down on you that would be a pleasure
and I can lick
and that would be delicious and yes I
would do it with great detail and I
would love to do it and it would be
really nice and I'll get in there and
it'll be a real pleasure to do it it
would just be great oh I love the way
you look at me it's just so nice and
I'll just get down there and licky lick
it's going to taste good and I'll tell
everybody about it it would just be
wonderful it'll be a good time for me
and I'll tell everybody and we'll put it
on Instagram and could I just do you
think I could do that or maybe should I
well yes you can go down on me you can
go
down awardwinning people awardwinning
analysis any who uh let's go to the man
that is apparently in charge of Camala
Harris who hired her because she is a
black woman those are his words not mine
uh you may remember his first campaign
speech when he was running last time and
we should have known that there was
something wrong with him and we were
going to end up in this situation here's
a here's a quick hit from from the old
days my name's Joe Biden I'm Joe Biden's
husband and C's running
meate kidy aside thank you
kamla
nobody even knows how to react anyway
here's uh Biden yesterday and uh the man
is struggling the man is struggling
we'll teach Donald Trump an valuable
lesson don't mess with a women America
unless you want to get the
benefit can we get close captioning on
that one would that be possible that
would blow out the system we don't even
have the computing power to figure that
one out we actually got that one from
another angle take a look at this we'll
teach Donald Trump an valuable lesson
don't mess with
them I think Liar Liar is Jim carre's
best movie what do you guys think I I
could see the argument for the mask Dumb
and Dumber you think it's I can see it
Dumb and Dumber The Mask wow we're gonna
have to argue this one out anyway what
is the point of showing you all of this
we do not know if Biden is going to be
the nominee that is just the Flatout
truth right A man is 80 years old or 81
years years old he is breaking down the
people that are applauding him he and
then and then they applaud like it's
this like train seal thing but we have
no idea if he's going to be the nominee
which If he if he literally trips today
Camala Harris is President tonight and
they have other plans to get rid of her
there's no doubt about that I was on
Pier's Morgan a couple days ago in New
York City uh and we talked a bit about
Joe Biden's sort of crumbling mental
state and what that means for the whole
damn thing here's the thing I think the
problem it's not excuse it's not his age
I think that Joe Biden's problem is the
clear senility yeah that's going with
his age like I said I met mck Jagger
last summer absolutely bursting with the
vi and vigor that Jill wants us to
believe she sees in go look Piers do any
of us sitting at this table or anyone
watching this think that he could run
one shift at McDonald's and I don't mean
that as a shot for someone that works at
McDonald's
but but I don't think he could I think a
lot of senior citizens could cuz I don't
think it's an age thing I agree with you
it's it's a cognitive Collins at the
emys stole the show she's 90 years old
good friend of mine she looks about 50
and she has the mental acuity of a
50-year-old she has vim and vigor so I
know Jill Biden is right to say it's
about vim and vigor but her husband
doesn't exude it well look let's put it
this way you opened by saying something
about ailing Joe Biden and thought oh I
haven't looked at my phone in 20 minutes
did something else happen it's a general
ailing it's ailing yes we all know it
the wandering off when they put get him
off the plane and the confusion he
literally on camera last what was it two
years ago said let's go let's go Brandon
like something is not right we all know
it and I would say respectfully in terms
of the polls and everything people don't
vote on what really matters we vote on
what we can feel right and I think
because of that people are going Donald
Trump he back there's energy there and
there's just no energy with Biden nobody
nobody like of the clips of that guy I
keep telling you more more of that guy
whoever he is uh the point of all of
that is that if we all know that there
is something wrong with Joe Biden and at
the same time we have some sense perhaps
from New Hampshire that the crossover
people are not thrilled with Trump then
what we need to do if you do not want
Joe Biden or Camala Harris or Gavin nuum
to be president we have to now push on
Trump a little bit to figure figure out
a way to get those moderates get those
it's it often is Suburban women who have
that major aversion to Trump and if
because if we don't do that we're going
to get the Democrats again I want to
show you two clips uh right now of Rona
santis yesterday because DeSantis who's
not running for president he is now back
Donald Trump that is that is absolutely
fine he's back here in Florida and as a
Floridian I'm I'm very happy about that
actually um but he went on the Steve da
show on The Blaze and he talked about uh
well steeve basically asked him if he
has any regrets and I think what he
talks about here is an important way
that we can kind of push on Donald Trump
the one of the frustrating things with
the campaign was I was the only one that
wanted to talk about this uh no one else
wanted to talk about covid I think there
was one question of in all the debates
that brought up that brought up Co I had
to inject it into different debates
whether it's fouchy whether it's
accountability you name it but this was
one of the biggest events in our life uh
and yet we had we had one candidate who
was president at the start of it and
when he get interviewed no one would
even ask him questions about it uh and
so I think what we're doing is is
important I think that it it potentially
can can lead to some some reform uh but
one of the you know the the the the
regrets I have about kind of what how 24
is turning out is I don't see at the
federal level there being any Avenue for
covid accountability I think that you
know you're going to have two major
candidates that just that just want to
pretend like everything was hunky dory
and and I know and both of those
presidents made serious serious mistakes
and here's the thing it's not about
using it for fod in a political campaign
it's about ensuring that this never
happens to our country ever again okay
so the reason I wanted to show you that
is when I talk about the people on the
left the sane voices on the left pushing
against the excesses of the left right
so whether it is John fedman which I
still can't believe or Bill Maher when
he occasionally does it or van Jones
when he checks into reality land every
now and again having the same voices
even if you disagree with these people
on virtually everything having somewhat
of a San voice on the other side is good
right it helps moderate it and Ronda
santis who obviously isn't going to be
president and is now back here in
Florida uh I think he is right when he
talks about that that if we don't ever
get that covid accountability which is
just one of several things that he was
pushing on um we we are bound to do it
again so having a descent is kind of
what he's doing there he's nudging Trump
a little bit right because he knows that
a lot of people supported him and
certainly a lot of people supported him
on the covid stuff so it's good to have
those voices on the right be like oh you
know let's not forget what happened
during covid and let's have that
accountability because more than
anything else and I got one more clip
for you more than anything else and and
bigger than politics is standing up for
what's right there is virtue in that and
you have no idea what can happen if you
do The Virtuous thing you just don't
know how that will spread it will JP I'm
speaking to there's lots of people who
are in this situation like you know
people at universities and corporations
all over the place I I you know Google
is not the only company that
isos not the worst repressive uh freedom
of speech denying workplace codes and
everybody feels
alone right there all like why should I
stand up be a martyr get fired this guy
at Google got fired yeah what's the
point it's a good question and how do
you how do you convince people that
there's a point to to to standing up
when it appears to be
futile well the first thing I think is
you convince them that it's not
futile it might be
difficult but it's not futile if you get
your words right and you have something
to say there'll be an impact of those
words it might not be the impact that
you would choose but the but the other
thing you got to tell people is pick
your
poison you don't you may be in a
situation where you don't have a you
don't have a cakewalk to the Garden of
paradise you got tyranny or famine those
are your choices but you get to pick
which one you have and I would say if if
you're being oppressed and I mean in
your soul by what you're required to
swallow follow at work well you think
you're not paying a price for that you
got no self-respect and and and and
rightly so but worse than that you're an
agent of your own destruction you're
destroying your own ideal and you're
letting people who are weak and
corrupt
win and if you stood up and and stood up
properly but you have to put yourself in
order to do this at least to some degree
right you can't do it casually you have
to do it from some position of
preparedness and strength then what
makes you think you couldn't scare them
back into the corners and that would be
a good
thing ain't that right that guy is
pretty quotable the one quote that I'll
repeat it might be difficult but it is
not futile isn't that the point of all
of this that's standing up for the right
thing even pushing back on your side
which is which is often harder right I
can sit here on this show every day and
on the left at this point Dave Ruben
left the left and oh my God he's making
fun of the left holy cow well that it
comes with a certain cost sometimes
lefties aren't nice to me on Twitter but
it is much harder to push back against
the excesses of the people that I might
end up voting for or the people who I
have more common cause with that's how
you how you build something better right
and that's what I intend to do and I
would liken that to something that I
mentioned at the top of the show uh the
last 5 days of our show every single day
we have broken every subsequent record
Thursday was our best day ever Friday
was our best day ever including the day
before Saturday Sunday Monday maybe
today will as well I had no idea a year
ago when we got into this presidential
race if I supported disantis what was
that going to do to my trump people now
saying I'm going to back Trump is that
going to get my disantis people pissed
off do I have some moderates angry at me
for whatever I just did what I thought
was right and and the proof is in the
pudding on the numbers on that and that
is what I will continue to do and I
think that's what you have to do with
with with your life you can take an
unpopular stance I took an unpopular
stance within the right right Des santis
did not win Trump won by a lot I took an
unpopular stance but it was not the
wrong stance and now as someone that
stood up for what I believe in I hope
that I can continue to be a voice that
in those moments that Trump's going off
the deep end instead of the worship that
I'm able to do my part which which
actually would be defending much more
than the views of this show it would be
it would be defending and helping build
a world that I want to live in and I
think you can be a part of that as well
uh guys reminder part one of my
interview with former CIA agent Mike
Baker is up right now the full thing is
on locals uh people of the internet with
Isabelle Brown 1 p.m. and we got a
postgame show in about 30 seconds at
Ruben report. locals.com um
[Music]
adios